Welcome back.
Well we're now on number 4.
And just so you know how
considerate I am of your time,
I drew this very fancy graphic
before the video just so not
to waste your valuable time.
So let's read the question.
This is the graph that they--
and this X right here is
number of children.
And these are years.
So the question says, the graph
above shows how the
Jackson family continued to grow
between 1991 and 1998 by
indicating the total number of
children in the family at the
end of each year.
The Jackson's have one set of
twins who were born to Miss
Jackson one year-- because they
couldn't have been born
to Mr. Jackson-- who
are born to Miss
Jackson one year in July.
During what year were
the twins born?
Well let's see, this graph, you
see the years, each year
they say how many children
are in the family.
So we can figure out how many
children are born in each year
just by figuring out how much
does the graph move up.
For example, there were-- let
me say children born.
And you could do this in your
head during the exam because
you have to do it really, really
fast. But I'll explain
it a little bit more basically
so that you can make
sure you get it.
So in 1991 were any
children born?
Well no, because they
had no children.
In '92 they went from
having 0 children in
'91 to having 1 child.
So the 1 child was born in
'92, and then how many
children were born in '93?
Well they had 1 child in '92 and
they had 1 child in '93,
so no children were
born in '93.
I think you see what
I'm doing.
I'm getting the difference
between one year and the next
because that's how
many children are
born in that year.
From '93 to '94, we went from
1 to 2 children, so 1 child
was born that year.
So there was 1 child born.
Same thing in '95.
The number of children
increased by 1.
So there was 1 child born.
'96, the number of children
stayed the same.
No new children were born.
We had 3 at the end of
'95, and we had 3
at the end of '96.
So no new children were born.
So that's a 0.
And then in '97, we go from
having 3 children at the end
of '96 to having 5.
So 2 children must have
been born that year.
And then in '98, we had the
same number of children.
And of course, they should have
said in the question, but
we can assume that no children
died during the
course of this problem.
I don't want to be morbid.
But anyway, so no children
were born in '98, so 0.
So the question is, what year
were the twins born?
Well twins, that's 2 children,
if my biology is correct.
So the year is 1997, which
is choice number D.
I feel very bad having to erase
this beautiful drawing,
but the things I do in the
name of education.
Number 5-- no drawing
for Sal in number 5.
The average arithmetic
mean of X and Y is 5.
So average-- let me write mean
because if has fewer letters.
They should have another math
term called nice I think.
But the mean of x and
y is equal to 5.
And what does that mean?
That means that the average-- so
we also know that x plus y
over 2 is equal to 5-- I just
took the average of them.
And the average of
x, y and z is 8.
What is the value of z?
Fascinating.
So we also know that the mean
of x, y and z is equal to 8.
And then they want to
know what is z?
Well the mean of x, y and z is
equal to 8-- that's just if we
took the average of them.
That's x plus y plus z
over 3 is equal to 8.
This is the exact same
way of saying this.
You can review the average
play-- I think it's in my
pre-algebra playlist
if you don't
remember how to take averages.
But how do we solve for z here,
because we have three
variables and only two
equations, it seems very
complicated.
But I'll show you a trick,
and this is actually a
very common SAT trick.
So you take this first equation
and we can't solve
for x and we can't solve
for y, but we can
solve for x plus y.
So we just multiply both sides
of that equation by 2 and we
get x plus y is equal to 10.
x plus y is equal to 10.
And then we can substitute
the whole x plus y here.
This is something you seldom
see in your algebra classes
because you're always solving
for one variable for other.
Now you can almost use x
plus y as a variable.
Like the whole thing
is a variable.
It's kind of strange,
but that's
how you do this problem.
Algebra, there's nothing
fancy here.
I'm saying x plus y is equal to
10, literally in English.
So we could say well this
x plus y is equal to 10.
So we could re-write this top
equation as 10 plus z over 3
is equal to 8.
And then if we multiply both
sides by 3 you get 10 plus z
is equal to 24.
And then you subtract 10 from
both sides and you get z is
equal to 14, and we are done.
That wasn't too bad, was it?
Good, the choice exists,
choice B for number 5.
All right, number 6.
So I'm drawing for Sal.
I like these, these are fun.
Let me draw in magenta.
That's the big figure.
In the figure above-- I don't
know how to change my
background color.
In the figure above,
a small square is
inside a larger square.
What is the area in terms of
x of the shaded region?
Well let me just work with what
I have. So they have a
smaller one here,
then a smaller.
And then let me use
this thing.
Create a shaded region.
Let me create a shaded region.
Look at that-- look at the
amazing tool I'm using.
It's called paint.
So what was I doing.
Oh, this is x.
Oh, I'm using the same color.
Let me use a vivid color.
One side of this is x, one
side of this is x.
And then the sides of the
big square are 5 and 5.
And they just want to know, what
is the area in terms of x
of the shaded region?
Well the shaded region, that's
this brown area, the area of
that is going to be the area
of this entire square minus
the area of the smaller square,
right, because we took
this out of the shaded region.
So the area of the big square--
well the area of a
square or a rectangle is just
the height times the width.
So that's 5 times 5, so it's
25, minus the area of the
smaller square.
And that's just going to be x
times x, which is x squared.
That equals the area, and
that is choice E.
All that drawing for such
an easy problem.
I hope you don't find that I'm
being cocky when I call it an
easy problem.
If you find it difficult,
it wasn't that easy, I
understand.
Anyway, number 7.
Let me erase my drawing.
If rstv equals 1.
Let me write that down.
And stuv equals 0.
Which of the following
must be true?
Let me write these down.
So they're saying choice
A-- I'm going to
write all the choices.
Choice A, r is less than 1.
Choice B is s is less than 1.
Choice C is t is greater
than 1/2.
Choice D, u is equal to 0.
And choice E, v is equal to 0.
So which of the following
must be true?
Well the first thing we know,
we know rstv is equal to 1.
So we know that none of rst or
v can be 0, because if any of
them were 0 than when you
multiply them out, they
couldn't equal 0, right?
So rstv all must be
some non-0 number.
So if we go back here, we know
that s is non-- and then if we
go into this equation we know
that one of them must be 0, at
least 1, because when you
multiply them you get 0.
Because 0 times any
number is 0.
So we know that s is not
0 because it's up here.
Because we said all of these
numbers cannot be 0.
We know t cannot be 0 because
it's up here.
Because if it was 0, this
would have been 0.
And we know v cannot be 0
because it's up here.
And all we're left with is
that u is equal to 0.
I'll see you in the
next video.